qui a commencé quand j'avais 13 ans et a duré 5 ans,
m'a permis d’être qui je suis.
Et plus tard, qui je devais devenir.
Avant son départ, ma mère avait été ma cachette humaine.
Elle était la seule personne qui semblait aussi étrange que moi,
une étrangeté magnifique,
un mélange entre Blanche DuBois dans « Un tramway nommé Désir »
et une Whitney Houston des années 80.
(Rires)
Je ne dis pas qu'elle était parfaite,
mais je dois dire que j'ai profité de ses imperfections.
Et c'est peut-être ça, la magie :
une erreur utile.
Donc quand elle a commencé à disparaître pendant des jours,
j'ai eu recours à ma propre magie.
Il m'est venu à l'esprit, miraculeusement,
que je pouvais faire apparaître ma mère en marchant parfaitement
de mon école primaire située en haut d'une pente raide
jusqu'en bas chez ma grand-mère,
en mettant un pied, un seul pied, sur chaque pavé du trottoir.
Il ne fallait pas que mon pied touche la ligne entre les pavés
ou que je saute un pavé
jusqu'au dernier pavé et au dernier brin d'herbe
qui séparait notre jardin de notre allée de garage.
Et je vous jure, ça a marché.
Une fois seulement.
Mais si ma marche parfaite ne pouvait pas me ramener ma mère,
j'ai réalisé que cette démarche avait une tout autre utilité.
Tous les gens responsables autour de moi
n'aimaient rien d'autre que la perfection,
l'obéissance, la soumission.
Du moins, ils me laissaient tranquille lorsque je me soumettais.
Alors j'ai fait un marché
que j'ai retrouvé plus tard dans une prison de la Stasi à Berlin,
sur un panneau qui disait :
« Celui qui s'adapte vit tolérablement. »
C'était un marché qui me garantissait
un endroit où vivre et de quoi manger ;
un marché qui m'a gratifié d'éloges de mes profs, de ma famille, d'inconnus ;
un marché qui avait l'air de bien payer
le jour où, à 17 ans, quelqu'un de Yale est venu me recruter
pour l'équipe de football.
J'ai été aussi surpris que vous l'êtes aujourd'hui.
L'homme de Yale a dit - tout le monde a dit -
que c'était la meilleure chose qui puisse m'arriver,
la meilleure qui puisse arriver à la communauté entière.
« Prends ce billet, mon garçon », m'ont-ils dit.
J'avais des doutes.
Yale semblait être un tout autre monde :
froid, étrange, hostile.
Le premier jour de mon recrutement,
j'ai envoyé un SMS à ma sœur pour ne pas y aller.
« Ces gens sont trop bizarres. »
Elle a répondu : « Tu te sentiras à ta place. »
(Rires)
J'ai pris le billet,
j'ai travaillé dur pour me sentir à ma place.
Quand le conseiller des 1ères années m'a dit d'éviter les casquettes...
« Tu es à Yale maintenant. C'est fini tout ça », disait-elle.
Je me suis dit, c'est l'un des petits prix
à payer pour y arriver.
Je les ai tous payés, j'ai essayé,
et effectivement ça a eu l'air de payer en retour :
j'ai été leader de l'équipe universitaire de football,
j'ai intégré une confrérie pas si secrète que ça
et obtenu un travail à Wall Street, puis Washington.
Les choses allaient si bien que j'ai songé, tout naturellement,
à devenir Président des Etats-Unis.
(Rires)
Mais vu que je n'avais que 24 ans
et que les présidents doivent eux aussi débuter quelque part,
je me suis contenté d'une campagne pour le Congrès.
C'était au lendemain de cette fantastique élection de 2008
durant laquelle un sénateur modéré et sérieux a souligné :
« Le message qu'il faut faire passer par-dessus tout
est que Barack Obama est un homme comme nous. »
Ils ont si bien fait passer ce message
que leur campagne est devenue le modèle d'excellence en politique,
voire un modèle de la vie moderne, ce qui semble aussi exiger que
chacun de nous fasse tout son possible pour pouvoir, au moment ultime,
dire avec paix et satisfaction : « J'étais juste comme tout le monde. »
Et mon message serait le même.
Alors un soir, j'appelle mon éventuel directeur de campagne.
On avait fait ce qu'il fallait pour gagner mais il avait d'abord une question :
« As-tu autre chose à me dire ? »
J'ai fini par lui dire :
« Il vaudrait mieux que tu saches que je suis gay. »
Silence.
« Hum. Je vois », a-t-il presque murmuré,
comme s'il avait trouvé une pièce d'or ou un oisillon mort.
(Rires)
« Tu as bien fait de me le dire », a-t-il continué.
« Mais tu ne rends pas mon boulot facile.
Tu es quand même au Texas.
Mais ce n'est pas impossible, non non.
Mais Casey, je te pose la question :
Comment réagiras-tu si on te traite de pédé lors d'un réunion publique ?
Et soyons réalistes, OK ?
Tu te doutes bien que quelqu'un voudra sans doute se montrer violent.
Je veux juste savoir :
Es-tu vraiment prêt à vivre ça ? »
Je ne l'étais pas.
Et je n'arrivais pas à comprendre :
je n'arrivais presque plus à respirer,
à penser, ou à dire quoi que ce soit.
Mais soyons clairs : le garçon que j'étais alors
aurait sauté sur l'occasion de se faire blesser,
et de tout sacrifier, même sa vie, pour une cause.
Il y avait pourtant quelque chose de choquant.
Ça n'avait pas lieu d'être, mais c'était là :
dans l'idée qu'il se ferait blesser pour la seule raison d'être lui-même,
ce qu'il n'avait même pas essayé d'être en premier lieu.
Il croyait - je croyais - que tout ce que j'avais essayé
de faire et d'être, c'était ce qu'on attendait de moi.
J'étais connu à 24 ans :
j'étais intelligent, je parlais bien, m'habillais bien, j'étais un bon citoyen.
Mais le marché que j'avais accepté ne sauvera ni moi,
ni vous non plus.
Cette leçon, vous l'avez déjà apprise,
ou vous l'apprendrez, quelle que soit votre sexualité.
Les homos en reçoivent sans aucun doute une dose concentrée,
mais la répression est une pilule amère qui nous est offerte à tous.
On nous apprend à cacher tant d'aspects de notre identité et de nos parcours :
notre amour, notre douleur, pour certains, notre foi.
Dévoiler son homosexualité peut être pénible,
le dévoilement de soi dans toute sa pure et étrange magie est plus dur.
Miles Davis a dit: « Il faut du temps avant de trouver sa propre voix. »
C'était le cas pour moi.
À 24 ans j'ai eu cette révélation personnelle,
mais j'ai continué à vivre ma vie.
Je suis allé à Harvard Business School, j'ai créé un organisme à but non lucratif,
fait la couverture d'un magazine, été sur scène à TED.
(Rires)
J'avais atteint, à presque 30 ans,
presque tout ce dont un gamin peut rêver.
Mais j'étais à bout :
pas vraiment en pleine crise de nerfs, mais pas loin,
dans tous les cas, j'étais horriblement triste.
Je n'avais jamais pensé être un écrivain,
je n'avais même jamais vraiment lu jusqu'à mes 23 ans.
Mais le commerce du livre est la seule industrie
qui vous paye pour étudier vos propres problèmes, alors...
(Rires)
alors j'ai décidé d'essayer,
pour retracer ces fissures avec des mots.
Ce qui est apparu sur la page reflétait l'étrangeté que je ressentais alors,
ce qui a inquiété certaines personnes au départ.
Un écrivain respecté est venu pour intervenir de lui-même
après avoir lu les premiers chapitres,
et il a dit, tout comme ma mère :
« Écoute.
On t'a commissionné pour écrire une autobiographie.
C'est simple.
Il y a un début, un milieu et une fin,
et ça s'appuie sur les événements de ta vie.
Il y a d'ailleurs une grande tradition autobiographique dans ce pays,
menée par les marginaux qui écrivent pour revendiquer leur vie.
Va acheter ces livres et instruis-toi.
Tu pars dans la mauvaise direction. »
Mais je ne croyais plus ce qu'on nous apprenait -
que la bonne direction est la plus prudente.
Je ne croyais plus ce qu'on nous apprenait -
que les homosexuels, noirs ou pauvres sont des marginaux.
Je croyais ce que Kendrick Lamar dit dans « Section.80. » :
« Je ne suis ni en dehors regardant à l'intérieur,
ni en dedans regardant à l'extérieur.
Je suis en plein milieu et je regarde autour. »
(Rires)
C'était de ce point de départ
que je voulais travailler,
dans la seule direction d'intérêt, la mienne,
pour essayer de tous nous aider à refuser ces affreux marchés
qu'on nous a enseignés.
On nous a appris à nous changer
nous et notre travail en petites bouchées facilement digérables;
à nous mutiler pour pouvoir nous faire comprendre par les autres,
à nous nier pour nous faire de bons amis,
intégrer la bonne école, trouver le bon emploi,
être invité par le bon parti,
et, qu'un jour, le bon Dieu nous invite
à franchir les portes du Paradis
et qu'on L'adore ad vitam æternam.
Ce sont les récompenses, dit-on,
de notre obéissance :
être une bouchée pieuse, populaire
et mourir.
Et moi je dis : « Non merci. »
Au monde et à ma mère.
Enfin, pour tout vous dire,
J'ai juste dit : « OK Maman, à plus tard. »
(Rires)
Mais je me suis dit intérieurement : « Non, merci. »
Je ne peux pas accepter son marché.
Et vous non plus.
Ça serait facile pour beaucoup, comme nous ici
de nous considérer en sécurité,
de nous mettre de côté ici.
On parle bien, on s'habille bien,
on est intelligents, les gens nous aiment, ou font semblant.
Non, moi je dis : rappelons-nous de la femme de Loth.
Jésus de Nazareth l'a dit en premier à ses disciples :
« Rappelez-vous de la femme de Loth. »
Loth, au cas où vous n'auriez pas lu la Bible récemment,
a installé sa famille à Sodome,
au sein d'une société perverse que Dieu avait décidé de détruire.
Mais Dieu, dans sa cruauté, mais aussi dans sa bêtise,
fait accourir deux anges à Sodome pour dire à Loth de rassembler sa famille
et de fuir.
Loth a entendu le conseil de l'ange, mais s'est attardé.
Ils avaient autre chose à faire, alors ils ont pris les mains de Loth
les mains de ses filles, et les mains de sa femme,
et les ont faits vite sortir de Sodome.
Et les anges crient :
« Fuyez jusqu'aux montagnes. Et surtout, ne vous retournez pas »
au moment où Dieu fait pleuvoir du feu sur Sodome et Gomorrhe.
Je ne sais toujours pas comment Gomorrhe est impliqué.
Mais Loth et sa famille courent,
fuyant toute cette destruction,
détalant dans un nuage de poussière alors que Dieu sème la mort,
alors, pour une raison quelconque, la femme de Loth se retourne.
Dieu la transforme en statue de sel.
« Rappelez-vous de la femme de Loth », dit Jésus.
Mais j'ai une question :
pourquoi se retourner ?
Se retourne-t-elle pour ne pas manquer le chaos,
pour apercevoir une dernière fois la ville en feu ?
Voulait-elle s'assurer que ses proches
soient assez loin du danger et puissent souffler un peu ?
Je suis si curieux et égoïste parfois que je l'aurais fait pour ces raisons
si j'avais été à sa place.
Mais la femme de Loth avait peut-être autre chose en tête ?
Elle ne pouvait peut-être pas supporter l'idée de laisser ces gens
brûler vifs tous seuls,
même au nom de la vertu ?
C'est possible, non ?
Si oui, alors ce regard en arrière d'une femme désobéissante
n'est peut-être pas un récit de mise en garde.
C'est peut-être l'acte le plus courageux de toute la Bible,
plus courageux que l'acte qui unit et cimente le Livre,
la crucifixion.
On nous dit que sur Golgotha, en haut d'une vieille croix robuste
Jésus est mort pour tous nous sauver :
des milliards et des milliards d'étrangers pour l'éternité.
C'est gentil.
Ça l'a rendu célèbre, c'est sûr.
(Rires)
Mais la femme de Loth a été tuée,
transformée en statue de sel,
tout ça parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas tourner le dos à ses amis,
les pervers de Sodome,
et personne n'a écrit son nom nulle part.
Oh, avoir le courage de la femme de Loth.
C'est le genre de courage dont on a besoin aujourd'hui.
Le courage de se mettre là-bas.
Le courage qui refuse que ; tout le monde doit être pédé,
ou personne ne peut être pédé, pour que nous soyons libres.
Le courage de se tenir avec d'autres clochards dans la rue,
avec les misérables de la Terre,
pour former une armée avec les plus petits d'entre eux,
avec la conviction que, grâce à la croûte pure de nos êtres,
nous pouvons construire un monde meilleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)